- [Christine] Texas
representative has
filed a controversial bill, to
prevent county
clerks from issuing
same sex marriage licenses.
In fact, the bill
would discontinue
the salary of state or
local government employees
who issue marriage
licenses to gay couples.
- You want something
illegal to be
the law, to prevent
something legal,
because you don't like
that it's the law?
Man, that's some typical
Texas, diabolical
hickory smoked, brain
barbecue, alright.
What if ISIS rolled
into your bakery?
(laughs)
- They have, they have.
- They have?
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- We have a little
beheading this
weekend, we want a
cake to celebrate.
(laughs)
You're standing by a
quarry with Antonin Scalia.
- Is there math?
Okay.
- It's the middle of the night,
you've both been
drinking, no ones around.
If you push him over the edge,
the the democrat president can
appoint.
(laughs)
Another justice, what do you do?
- The nightly
show, Larry Wilmore
just asked, would
you commit murder?
(laughs)
- Hey, America,
Larry Wilmore here.
If you like The Nightly
Show on Comedy Central,
like us on Facebook too.
Just don't poke me, I
do not like being poked.
You can candy crush me.